la despedida a estos armenios recién
reclutados que ahora parten al frente de
batalla mientras tanto otros llegan a
inscribirse uniéndose a la lucha contra
azerbaiyán en la disputada región de
nagorno karabaj bueno todos tenemos que
prestar un servicio no podía quedarme
indiferente tenía que venir nagorno
karabaj es un enclave de mayoría armenia
que se independizó unilateralmente de
azerbayán en los años 90 estaba bajo el
control de separatistas armenios y
ningún país del mundo reconoce su
soberanía ambas partes se acusan de
haber comenzado el domingo unos
violentos enfrentamientos que han venido
en aumento también se señalan de apuntar
a objetivos civiles
azerbayán ha estado atacando
asentamientos e infraestructuras civiles
desde el mismo comienzo de la ofensiva y
podemos ver la evidencia de ello en toda
la región
son las tensiones internacionales crecen
de la mano del conflicto
armenia acusa a turquía aliado de
azerbayán de derribar uno de sus aviones
militares un ataque que turquía y
azerbaiyán niegan
ankara expresó el miércoles que harían
lo necesario cuando le preguntaron si o
sería ayuda militar sea sirva ya se lo
pide algunos aliados de turquía en la
otan dijeron estar alarmados por esa
postura entre ellos el presidente
francés emmanuel macro las falsas a
ningún de minsk dos walkies francia como
parte del grupo de ming se solicita la
imparcialidad que define mi advertencia
y permanece extremadamente preocupada
por los mensajes casi de guerra que
llegan desde turquía en las últimas
horas
ese miércoles rusia ofreció albergar
negociaciones entre las dos ex
repúblicas soviéticas mientras que los
dos bandos rechazan las peticiones
internacionales de un cese el fuego o
una tregua